it was friday night and 17 year old
david faraday assured the parents of 16
year old betty lou jensen that he'd have
her home before 11.
it was december 20th 1968
and it was the young couple's first date
the vallejo california high school
classmates had met a couple of weeks
before at a church picnic
later as the clock closed in on 11 they
decided to end their night with a drive
up dark isolated lake hermann road to a
local lover's lane
their first date
would be their last
another couple leaving the spot later
recall seeing faraday's rambler parked
there around 11 10 pm they also dimly
recollected another car nearby
around 11 25 a distraught woman flagged
down two cops on routine patrol daniel
peta and bill warner
she told them there were two bodies
lying in the parking area off lake
hermann road
rushing there peta and warner spotted
betty lou jensen's body first
she was crumpled face down in a pool of
blood about 20 feet behind the rambler
she'd been shot in the back at least
five times one bullet piercing her heart
she was pronounced dead at the scene
near the driver's side of the vehicle
faraday lay sprawled face up he'd been
shot once straight through the head
he was still breathing but he never
regained consciousness before expiring
a reconstruction of the crime suggested
that the killer or killers had
confronted the couple as they got into
or out of the car
while david faraday was dispatched
swiftly with a bullet to the brain
betty lou jensen apparently made a run
for it before being cut down
the bullets were 22 caliber better
suited for killing small varmints than
humans
but the small rounds made little noise
beyond that there wasn't much evidence
to go on
initial suspicions of drug involvement
and jealous ex-boyfriends went nowhere
the young lover's murder case went cold
and would stay that way for almost seven
months
authorities didn't know it yet but they
were looking at the first definitive
victims of a serial killer who'd become
known as the zodiac
the zodiac sometimes been called the
american jack the ripper and there are
some similarities
first both are credited with five
canonical murder victims those that
everyone can agree on
but both are also widely assumed to have
killed more
zodiac for instance ultimately claimed
37 victims
he and the ripper also taunted
authorities with cryptic letters and
sent them bloody trophies from their
kills
but the gaping black hole at the heart
of both cases is that the identity of
the killer remains a mystery
and nothing excites interest and
speculation like a mystery
so both zodiac and ripper have spawned a
virtual cottage industry of theories
the case is a bewildering mixture of
tangents puzzles and red herrings the
zodiac slangs have been attributed to
everyone from the manson family to the
unabomber to satanic cultists
yet even the most serious suspects never
yielded enough evidence for an arrest
much less conviction
more than 50 years on the zodiac case
remains as cold as it was that chilly
night in 1968
the fascination remains too as does the
nagging fear that the zodiac might still
be out there
somewhere
in this exploration of the zodiac
mystery i'm not going to go chasing
suspects or try to decipher his cryptic
messages
instead i'm going to focus on the one
thing the zodiac was clear about his
motive
simply put he claimed to kill to collect
slaves
captive souls who would serve him in the
afterlife
does anyone actually do that well yes or
they did the ancient egyptians the
vikings and many others engaged in the
ritualistic practice of killing people
especially young pretty ones to become
servants in the great beyond
of course some argued that this twist
was just another part of the zodiac sick
mind games
but others see it as evidence that
occult beliefs influenced or guided his
murderous behavior
so let's take a closer look
in doing so i'm going to stick close to
zodiac's four definite attacks the ones
with tangible evidence to connect him
this isn't to argue that he didn't kill
others before or afterward but i want to
ground the discussion in what we know
i also want to fit zodiac into the
context of the numerous murders often
occult tinged that sprouted like
poisonous mushrooms around the san
francisco bay area during the late 1960s
and 1970s
we've already talked about zodiac's
first canonical killings the lake
hermann murders in december 1968.
remember it was quickly passed off as a
random homicide
the second attack took place almost
seven months later on july 4th 1969.
what the murderer was up to during the
meantime is just one of the innumerable
mysteries the second attack took place
at yet another popular parking spot
called blue rock springs park
just a few miles from lake hermon
both assaults also occurred around the
same time of night and the victims were
again a young male female couple
there were three important differences
in this second case however first the
killer used a heavier weapon a nine
millimeter semi-automatic
second he phoned police to report the
shooting soon afterward third and most
important he again left one of the
victims alive and this one lived to tell
on the evening of that july 4th 19 year
old michael maggio was relaxing at home
when his friend 22 year old darlene
farron stopped by around 10 30 p.m
darlene wanted to talk so they headed
out to the privacy of blue rock springs
they pulled into the dark parking area
shortly after midnight
soon after another car parked nearby
then just as quickly drove off
the car returned five minutes later and
pulled up right behind farron and mojo
with its lights on
a man got out with a large bright
flashlight and approached the passenger
window
but joe figured he was a cop and reached
for his wallet
then he heard a muffled sound and felt a
sharp pain in his neck and back
he'd been shot
as the bullets kept flying majo dived
into the back seat
the gunman shifted to darlene the
critically wounded major lay helpless as
she was shot again and again
as the attacker walked away mijo let out
a groan and the gunman returned to shoot
him twice more
then the assailant jumped in his car and
sped away
mojo never got a look at the man's face
but he later described him as white
dirtyish with a heavy build and brown
curly hair
though bleeding and in pain mojo was
able to flash the car's headlights to
attract attention
a few minutes later some kids arrived
and police were called
bajo was rushed to the hospital and
recovered
darlene farron was pronounced dead at 12
38 a.m
exactly two minutes later vallejo police
received a call traced to a pay phone
in a monotone voice a man said
i want to report a murder
he directed cops to blue rock springs
park and almost casually added
i also killed those kids last year
the zodiac had spoken though he didn't
yet have a name
26 days later almost identical letters
arrived at three bay area newspapers
each contained detailed confessions to
the lake hermann and blue rock springs
murders
and part of a coded message that
supposedly would reveal the killer's
identity
a threat was also included unless the
newspapers printed the coded message on
august 1st the writer warned he'd go on
a fresh killing spree
but he still didn't identify himself as
the zodiac
his signature was a circle with a cross
or cross hairs drawn over it
the newspapers duly printed the message
part of it was soon decoded it read
i like killing people because it is so
much fun
i will not give you my name because you
will try to slow down or stop my
collecting of slaves for my afterlife
on august 4th the san francisco examiner
newspaper received another letter
this one began with the immortal words
this is the zodiac speaking
weeks passed quietly until saturday
september 27th
when two college students decided to
spend the day at lake berryessa about 45
miles north of
20
vallejo
old brian hartnell and 22 year old
cecilia shepard found an isolated spot
to swim and relax
late that afternoon cecilia noticed a
strange man lurking near some trees
and then things got weird
the man suddenly approached holding a
gun and wearing a bizarre hood and bib
emblazoned with a crossed circle
he said he was an escaped convict and
promised that he was just going to rob
them and take their car
he forced cecilia to tie up brian and
did the same to her
then without another ward the stranger
put down his gun
pulled out a huge knife and began
savagely stabbing them both
before departing the scene zodiac
scrawled a crossed circle on the door of
their car along with the dates of the
first two murders and the most recent 27
september 69 6 30 by knife
an hour later napa police received a
call from a man in a phone booth he said
i want to report a murder
i'm the one who did it
hartnell and shepard were found alive
she died a few days later he survived
the first three zodiac attacks again
shared a number of things in common
first zodiac wasn't a very efficient
killer
five of six victims were still alive
when he left the scene two survived
next it may be most obviously his
victims were couples all in the prime of
life
and the attacks all occurred in rural
locales near bodies of water
each occurred at night or in the evening
though the berries assault took place in
daylight
so there was a definite pattern
a script is a necessary part of any
ritual including one aimed at collecting
souls
other common features of rituals are
alignment with the seasons or the
position of heavenly bodies especially
the moon
with a killer who dubbed himself the
zodiac you might expect to find some
astrological alignments
were there any
not really
the lake herman attack occurred on the
cusp between sagittarius and capricorn
blue rock springs happened during cancer
in lake berryessa libra
about the only correlation is that the
fourth attack which we've yet to discuss
also took place during libra
so what about the moon
the second and third murders took place
during waning gibbous moons
but the first took place under a waxing
crescent one finally the first two
killings transpired on the cusp between
friday and saturday and lake berryessa
took place on a saturday
that might have had some arcane
significance to the zodiac or it might
simply have been because he worked
during the week
and after all finding isolated couples
would be a lot easier on friday or
saturday nights than any other
the only definite common features of the
first three murders were physical
location and choice of victims
if there was a ritual it was a rough and
evolving one
in the first two attacks zodiac used a
handgun though different calibers
in the third at lake berryessa he used a
knife to assail his victims even though
he carried a gun
he also made a point of noting that
killing had been carried out by knife
we'll discuss the possible significance
of that further along
another twist in the lake berry essay
attack was that he used a costume
emblazoned with a cross circle
was this ritual attire or did he just
don the getup because a daylight attack
required a better disguise
now let's take a look at the fourth
attack on october 11 1969
beyond the fact that it took place late
on a saturday night just two weeks after
the lake berryessa attack it bears
almost no similarity to the others
the victim was paul stein a 29 year old
lone male cab driver
the location was san francisco's
presidio heights district not some
isolated rural spot
it wasn't close to the water and stein
was dispatched with a single shot to his
head
this was no frenzied assault
if zodiac hadn't torn off part of
stein's bloody shirt and sent pieces of
it to newspapers and police
probably no one would ever have
connected him to the crime
so did zodiac just abandon his
established pattern
or is there something else involved
my guess is that stein's murder wasn't
planned it smacks more of a killing of
opportunity or of necessity
stein's last communication with his
dispatcher just minutes before he was
slain
said that he was taking a fair to the
intersection of washington and maple
streets
instead they ended up a block away at
washington and cherry
simple confusion may have led to an
altercation that ended with zodiac
shooting stein
on a public street in full view of
witnesses
most damningly this time zodiac left
bloody fingerprints all over the cab
incriminating evidence of the first
degree
to me this attests to a monumental
screw-up not masterful design
from this point on zodiac can't be
definitely linked to any other murders
in the aftermath of stein's killing
zodiac shifted to making unfulfilled
threats against school children
but he also continued to boast of more
murders and more slaves though he never
mentioned who where or when
did the stein fiasco make him more
careful
or did he just lose his nerve
in october 1970 san francisco chronicle
reporter paul avery received a strange
halloween card
the front side featured a smiling
skeleton and the caption from your
secret pal
lower down the message continued
i feel it in my bones you ache to know
my name and so i'll clue you in
inside however the card read but why
spoil the game
more interesting was what zodiac wrote
on the back
there he misspelled the word paradise
which was printed vertically down the
middle of the card
the word slaves was written horizontally
across it
just like zodiac's crossed circle this
divided the back side of the card into
four quarters
in those he wrote by fire by gun by
knife by rope
recall that zodiac had earlier made a
special point of noting a killing by
knife
and he's also killed by gun
was he now using fire and rope to
dispatch his victims
he also warned that his new killings
would look like accidents or suicides
or was zodiac just toying with press and
police
in any case the halloween card also
boasted a haul of 14 afterlife slaves
however zodiac wasn't being original
it turns out that his four means of
death fire gun knife and rope are the
clearly featured elements of a death
wheel on the front cover of a western
comic book published in 1952
tim holt number 30.
inside it the complete death wheel is
shown to have 12 sections in other words
it's a death zodiac
legend has it the comic states that the
wheel was made for king solomon the
ruler of the gin
borrowing from a comic doesn't prove an
occult connection
but maybe it does show
that zodiac was an old comics fan
however the death wheel is also
reminiscent of zodiac's emblematic
crossed circle
so that deserves closer attention
to the casual viewer it might look like
a simple crosshairs
but it's much more and has a long
history in occult symbolism
and many meanings
the four parts of the circle can stand
for the four elements earth fire air and
water
the four directions north south east and
west
or the four seasons winter spring summer
and fall or even the four letters of the
name of god y h
w h
the four seasons of course are closely
related to what else the zodiac
a term that means wheel or circle of
animals
the cross circle is also known as the
celtic cross or odin's cross and today
has been widely embraced as a symbol by
white nationalists and neo-pagans
but zodiac's only apparent use of the
cross circle wasn't to chart the
movements of the heavens but to indicate
places on the ground
places connected to his past and future
attacks
or maybe it was just another mind game
to send people on wild goose chases
most notably on june 26 1970
zodiac mailed the san francisco
chronicle another letter along with a
gas station road map of california
on it he drawn a cross circle over mount
diablo a prominent geographic feature
about 35 miles east of the city
included were instructions that the zero
or top point of the circle be aligned to
magnetic north
a 32 character coded clue accompanied
the map
it supposedly gave directions to a bomb
he'd planted to blow up a school bus
a follow-up letter stated that the clues
involved radians and number of inches
along the radians
the mention of radians suggests a
passing familiarity with higher
mathematics
later some imaginative theorists argued
that meant zodiac had a connection to
unibomber ted kaczynski
but there's nothing else in the manner
or motives of the two men's crimes to
support a tie
other theorists argue that the mount
diablo radiance business showed how
zodiac used magnetic lines of force to
pick the spots for his crimes
well maybe but none of it adds up to
anything solid
the real question might be why mount
diablo
the peak is notable for two things first
it's the starting point for the land
survey system covering most of northern
and central california
it's literally at the center or the
crosshairs of the region's north-south
east-west grid so was zodiac familiar
with surveying
mount diablo is also known for something
else and that brings us back to the
occult angle
the name diablo or devil comes from the
spanish who allegedly got the notion
from the bulgones native americans
according to the story the bolgones held
the peak to be the home of a powerful
evil spirit or pui
that's led some modern cultists to imbue
the mountain with superstitious awe and
significance
was zodiac one of them
or was he at least aware of the
mountain's sinister reputation
that brings us to the larger context i
wanted to explore
zodiac's place among the many serial
killings and unsolved murders that
plagued the san francisco bay area and
other parts of the golden state in the
late 60s and early 70s
i see the zodiac killings as part of a
dark aftermath to 1967's summer of love
when san francisco reigned as capital of
the counter culture and visions of peace
love and understanding shimmered in a
haze of acid flashbacks
but alongside all this psychedelic
grooviness arose a baffling wave of
violence
1969 not only witnessed the zodiac but
also the murderous manson family and the
fatal stabbing of a young man by a
member of the hell's angels motorcycle
gang at the altamonte music festival
a killing carried out while the rolling
stones perform sympathy for the devil on
stage
irony
or ritual
hidden in plain sight
and that wasn't all
the bay area scene transformed into a
hunting ground for cereal and macabre
killers
there was 21 year old edmund kemper who
in late 1969
was released from the atascadero state
hospital after serving five years for
murdering his grandparents
in may 1972 he began abducting and
slaughtering young female hitchhikers
usually in pairs gaining the nickname
co-ed killer
he finally turned himself in after
killing his mother
during the same time the remains of
another seven young women and maybe as
many as 14 were found dumped along
roadways near santa rosa to the north
the so-called hitchhiker killer was
never caught
and this was very near zodiac territory
could some of them
have been his claimed victims
on the more occult end of the spectrum
there was the october 1974 ritualistic
murder in stanford university's memorial
church of 19 year old newlywed
arliss perry
and then there was the professed
satanist and cannibal stanley dean baker
in july 1970 police arrested baker and a
male companion south of big sur after a
hit and run accident
baker was 22 and looked like a typical
hippie except for the satanic bible he
carried
and the human finger bones in his
pockets
these he explained belonged to a montana
social worker who'd made the fatal
mistake of giving him a lift
after killing the vehicle's driver with
a 22 pistol a weapon also used by zodiac
baker ritually ate the man's heart and
stole his car
the fingers he took along for snacks
and there's more to baker's story
he claimed to have been introduced to
satanism and cannibalism when he joined
a blood drinking cult in colorado or
wyoming
he claimed to have been a member of a
cult called
four pie which purportedly carried out
human sacrifices disguised as random
murders
at its head said a mysterious leader
dubbed the gran chinggon
you can consult a spanish slang
dictionary to get the full meaning of
that name
baker also confessed to having murdered
a san francisco interior designer by the
name of robert salem
before leaving the scene baker wrote
zodiac on the wall
now since baker was in prison or
elsewhere when zodiac committed his
murders the two men couldn't be one in
the same
but could they have had a common
inspiration
it's at least worth noting that in 1966
shortly before zodiac began his rampage
the church of satan opened its doors in
san francisco
around the same time so did the
ominously named process church of the
final judgment
it was an offshoot of scientology that
among many other options
allowed his followers to worship satan
and wallow in a morass of violence
more interesting perhaps the process
church also had a swastika-like symbol
composed of four peas
just like baker's alleged murder cult
but if zodiac was a devil worshiper
you'd expect more hail satan's instead
of cross circles
also in comparing cannibal killer baker
in the zodiac it's worth noting that
baker once lived in colorado and did
prison time in montana
the survivor of the lake berryessa
attack david hartnell recalled zodiac
saying he had escaped from a prison in
montana or colorado
coincidence
probably
but as with so many other things in the
zodiac case you just never know for sure
zodiac was an enigma wrapped in a riddle
it's his mystery that accounts for our
continuing fascination with his crimes
and part of that mystery involves
tantalizing hints but no real proof that
he was involved with the occult
there's only one thing i can absolutely
assure you of
i'm not the zodiac
you